organisierte Kriminalität auf Instagram
gibt es das wirklich
wir machen uns auf die Suche nach
gefälschten Klamotten und Sneakern auf
Instagram
[Musik]
bei dem Handel mit gefälschten Waren
geht es nicht um Einzelfälle das
Geschäft dahinter verursacht ein
Milliardenschaden allein für Deutschland
für die Marken für Steuerzahler für
Kunden die darauf reinfallen
mir ist aufgefallen auf der Straße
laufen mega viele Leute mit meinen
Klamotten rum das sind teilweise Sneaker
die ich bei Pharrell Williams oder
Justin Bieber gesehen habe hier zum
Beispiel einer
ich frage mich bei solchen Leuten immer
wie kann er sich Schuhe leisten die hier
1000 Euro kosten
das Instagram Profil kommt eine komisch
vor darum schreibe ich einem Insider der
Kontakte in untergrundszenen hat er
schaut auf Social Media hinter die
Kulissen er ist mein erster Kontakt wenn
es um Kriminalität im Internet geht
undercover recherchiert er zu mafiösen
Strukturen darum will er hier nicht
erkannt werden
guck mal die sind doch mega teuer wie
kann er sich das leisten frage ich ihn
die sind gefälscht die echten Schuhe
haben eine ganz andere Form tragen alle
den Kram geh mal in die Fußgängerzone da
rennen so viele Kiddies mit gefälschten
Klamotten rum ich bin heute in der
Endstand unterwegs und will jetzt mal
ein bisschen herausfinden wie viel Fakes
sind wirklich auf den Straßen und dafür
gucken wir uns ganz viele Menschen an
ganz viele Schuhe und fragen ob die
Sachen echt sind oder nicht und
vielleicht erkenne ich auch ein paar
Sachen mal gucken
wir machen gerade ein bisschen
Straßenumfrage zu Klamotten tatsächlich
und ich wollte mal wissen was du für
Klamotten kriegst wenn es für dich cool
ist
was hast
du ja und die Schuhe sind Potenzial ganz
viel Trainer
wer kann der kann ne ja wo hast du die
hier gekauft Marokko ich hole den Weg
damit
Instagram auf dass du da manchmal solche
Sachen angezeigt bekommen ja ja auf
jeden Fall sehr viele zum Beispiel
Jordans Schuhe etc wie teuer ist das so
alles wie gesagt knapp 600 € gekostet ja
das ist 300 € gekostet
er ist überzeugt seine Weste ist
original wir checken das per QR-Code und
finden raus das Produkt ist fake
immer mehr Marken setzen mittlerweile
auf QR-Codes zu Echtheitsprüfung die man
mit dem Handy scannen kann ist die
Klamotte echt öffnet sich eine
identifikations-app ist die Klamotte
Fake wird man meist auf die Webseite der
Marke weitergeleitet
Umfrage habt ihr Bock uns ein paar
Fragen zu antworten
über Klamotten geht's
okay das Beste was du anhast oder das
ist dein wertvollstes Stück das neue
Schuhe bezahlt habe ich schon 180 aber
der wird davon liegen 450 Euro
es gefällt mir einfach vom optischen und
ich glaube darauf kommt dass es schön
aussehen dass es jemanden persönlich
gefällt die Schuhe sind wahrscheinlich
das krasseste dass du heute hast
du knapp 900 Euro
getroffen
finde ich also ich finde halt man sollte
dann dazu stehen sag mal was hast du
dran morgen
es ist original aus der Türkei es gibt
ja auch irgendwie so Fake Shops wo man
so reingehen kann wie kommt man da rein
weißt du das instagram
mein Eindruck ist mehr als die Hälfte
der Leute die wir angesprochen haben
hatte Fake Klamotten an und viele stehen
auch offen dazu und finden ihre Sachen
bei Instagram
die Social Media Plattform ist der
digitale Laufsteg der fashionindustrie
den weltweit ca 1,5 Milliarden Nutzer
sehen das hat Instagram allein in den
USA laut Prognose letztes Jahr über 33
Milliarden Dollar Werbeeinnahmen
eingebracht mit Werbung auf insta
verdient auch Willi Inland sein Geld er
ist einer der größten Sneaker Influenza
Deutschlands hallo
danke schön
von ihm will ich wissen wie werden
Markenklamotten überhaupt zum Hype und
damit als Fake zur lohnenden Handelsware
für Kriminelle
jede Woche neue ganze Zimmer vor
Kartons was machen denn Firmen um ein
halb entstehen zu lassen naja also ich
glaube die die einfachste Formel dafür
ist halt du kollaborierst mit einem
Künstler der gerade halt angesagt ist
bei jungen Menschen und dann kannst du
eigentlich machen was du willst weil es
wird eher erfolgreich sein es ist
Beispiel aktuell Travis Scott der Rapper
der mit Nike seit Jahren kollaboriert du
musst halt Leute haben die polarisieren
die eine Reichweite haben die wirklichen
influence auf die jungen Menschen haben
und ähm wenn die dann halt ein Produkt
rausbringen dann kaufen die Leute das
Blind es ist einfach so wie beurteilst
du die Rolle von Instagram also
Markenschuhe instagram ist halt
eigentlich glaube ich mit tiktok
mittlerweile der der größte
Multiplikator eben um halb zu zu
vervielfachen die eine Person die das
Produkt XY zeigt im in der Kamera und
wenn es nur für zwei drei Sekunden ist
irgendwas antiefern reicht schon aus und
so ein halb zu kreieren das heißt sich
innerhalb von zwei Überstunden sowas
komplett im Netz verbreitet ja das ist
schuhzimmer seine Sammlung ungefähr 200
Paar Schuhe alles Originale wir sind so
die Sachen die ich jetzt gerade aktuell
trage was ist so der besondersste
Studien du hast naja besonders zu Schuh
von der Qualität her ist glaube ich
schon der Dior und der kam auch raus vor
zwei oder drei Jahren der Lauer hat den
retail von 1800 und der High von 2400
und das ist halt ein made in Italy
Schuhe also das qualitativ hat ganz
anders als die asiatische produzierten
Schuhe und es ist ein teuerster Schuh
nee das ist tatsächlich
nicht gedacht weil das ist Tom Sack
Künstler seines Zeichen und ich habe den
damals für ich glaube 900 € oder so
gekauft und der wenn du den jetzt in der
Größe sozusagen in der condition
verkaufen wird es bist du so bei
roundabout viereinhalb bis 5000
diesen Schuh gibt es nur in limitierter
Stückzahl das macht ihn so wertvoll eine
Strategie vieler Hersteller der
hypregulierte Markt
verkünstliche Verknappung funktioniert
immer egal was bei was du es machst egal
ob das bei Möbel ist bei essen oder bei
Klamotten oder bei Schuhen oder während
der schlimmsten corona-lockdowns mit dem
Klopapier in die Leute merken okay es
gibt irgendwas nicht unbegrenzt dann
kaufen Sie es dann wollen sie es dann
steigen die Preise und dann ja das ist
halt normaler Zyklus im Kapitalismus wie
siehst du die Rolle von fake-schule ja
ich glaube es wird automatisch mehr mit
dem feldschuhen weil eben das der Trend
dahin geht dass die Schuhe die wirklich
sehr begehrt sind immer teurer werden
immer unerschwingliche für Menschen die
normale Geld verdienen ich merke das ja
auch in den Kommentaren wieder Leute
schreiben ja dann hole ich mir über den
replica für 50 € oder selbst Replikation
in der mittlerweile ganz gut teuer
geworden tatsächlich
früher produzierten die Fälscher im
geheim heute nutzen Sie Instagram sie
werden mit bester Qualität beste
Material neuesten Maschinen und
druckqualifizierte Personal das Ergebnis
ihrer Arbeit perfekte Fälschung
sogenannte super Clowns selbst von
Experten kaum noch vom Original zu
unterscheiden
vom Insider weiß ich der Weg die
Fälschungen zu finden ist kinderleicht
eigentlich reicht es nach dem Hashtag
Sneaker zu suchen oder direkt nach dem
Lieblingsschuh es gibt diesen Nike
Supreme
so und es gibt jetzt diesen weißen hier
so Sorte schon bei den ersten Treffern
sind Schuhe dabei die ganz offen als
Fake angeboten werden viele dieser Shops
schreiben auch direkt ihre
whatsapp-nummer dazu das macht die
Bestellung super einfach
[Musik]
ich habe das gelernt bei ebay
kleinanzeigen man muss gar nicht mehr
schreiben
so jetzt muss ich auf eine Antwort
okay
aber sie können mich nur
erreichen wenn sie auch Geschäftszeiten
haben China Teilen China time
nur die haben gerade zugemacht
per WhatsApp schreibe ich noch weitere
Händler an die Chats laufen meist so ich
schicke dem Verkäufer meine Adresse er
mir sein Paypal ich soll das Geld als
Freunde oder Familie senden also ohne
Versicherung und im Betreff keine Angabe
zum Inhalt machen bin echt gespannt wie
viel davon durch den Zoll kommt
ich gehe besser auf Nummer sicher und
Schoppe noch ein bisschen auf insta
später Kesha
der Instagram Algorithmus sorgt dafür
dass ich Menschen mit den gleichen
Interessen finden das ist wie mit den
Katzenvideos je öfter man sie liked
desto häufiger bekommt man sie zu sehen
wenn man die Shops in China einmal
gefunden hat fehlen nur noch zwei swipes
und dann ist man schon bei real
existierenden underground-shops direkt
in der Nachbarschaft
okay was ist jetzt Phase wir stehen
jetzt hier auf einem Parkplatz unweit
von einem Fake Shop also ein
Klamottenladen oder Lagerhalle keine
Ahnung der Fake Klamotten auf Instagram
präsentiert ich weiß nicht so recht was
mich da erwartet deswegen habe ich alle
meine persönlichen Gegenstände abgelegt
habe auch ein anderes Handy und ich bin
schon seit ein paar Tagen mit dem Shop
Besitzer weil die Telefonnummer steht
einfach offen auf Instagram in Kontakt
und der hat mir gerade schon diese
Sprachnachricht geschickt
deswegen gehe ich jetzt hin habe nur
Bargeld dabei keine Ahnung was mich da
erwartet bisschen mulmig geb ich zu ist
mir schon aber ja
Schuhe wollen gekauft werden deswegen
sieht das in der Realität wirklich so
aus wie mir der illegale Shop das hier
ganz offen auf Instagram präsentiert
es
ist 12 weil es die Braut man auf den
streetsalons lieb ich bin real mein Team
ist in Wien und Berlin
[Musik]
das ist halt so ein storage einfach
gewesen so ein storage was man mieten
kann und die oberste Etage war einfach
komplett leer und da war nur ein
Container und da haben die mit schönen
Lichterketten dekoriert Ihren Shop
hingebracht eingebaut und der war auch
Propofol mit so Schuhen und Parfums
Taschen und der wurde geführt von so
drei Jungs und die waren super
freundlich super nett
und haben mir Sachen verkauft und die
zeige ich jetzt das erste
hier dieses Verarbeitung das ist alles
nicht so ganz so schön
und auch hier ähm Qualität ist jetzt
auch nicht so geil rum so ähm zwei
Parfums von yveson
packen Zigaretten weil ich irgendwie
crazy Fantasie auch Zigaretten hatten
ganz wichtig für später im Hotel viagra
habe ich auch noch nie so gesehen dass
das auf Viagra ist offenbar da haben wir
noch eine Hose kann man ja mitnehmen
aber billig tatsächlich Schuhe fand ich
relativ teuer haben 120 Euro gekostet
was ich für so ein für so ein Preis in
so einem
relativ teuer fand der geile Lacoste
Trainingsanzug das ist tatsächlich auch
ganz geil einge
printet hier hinten auch dieses Krokodil
obwohl nee vielleicht auch nicht jetzt
habe ich noch was geschenkt bekommen das
ist wohl so ein türkischer Honig hat
gesagt
und der ist wohl auch ähnlich wie Viagra
nur macht nicht so viel Kopfschmerzen er
meinte es wäre rein pflanzlich aber
ich bin immer so ein bisschen skeptisch
was soll ich sagen angeht später stoßen
wir auf eine vom Zoll den Auftrag
gegebenen Analyse die zeigt der
Wirkstoff ist derselbe wie bei Viagra es
handelt sich bei der Verpackung um eine
von schmucklern beliebte Methode das
Medikament über die Grenze zu bringen
Fazit des Abends das breite Sortiment im
fake-shop weist auf organisierte
Kriminalität hin bei der Recherche auf
Instagram haben wir jede Menge illegale
Shops gefunden auffällig viele davon im
Ruhrgebiet einer Schätzung zufolge
entstand 2022 in Deutschland ein Schaden
von über 60 Milliarden Euro durch
Produkt und Markenpiraterie
mit welchen Strukturen man es dazu tun
hat weiß Konstantin rehhag er vertritt
große Modemarken wie zum Beispiel
Supreme und berät die Europäische
Kommission in Urheberrechtsfragen wir
waren vorgestern in so einem Shop im
Ruhrgebiet
den wir einfach über Instagram
angeschrieben haben haben Sie schon mal
was von solchen Shops gehört sowas kenne
ich natürlich
auch schon durchaus im Rahmen von
Hausdurchsuchungen besucht haben da sind
wir dann natürlich auch als Produkt
Experten dabei natürlich kann man der
Polizei nur mal hypothetisch bescheid
sagen oh das ist ein Shop und ich glaube
die vertreibender fällt schon
da kann die Polizei nicht viel tun und
dann muss man in dieser Situation
natürlich erstmal zusehen dass man
gerichtsverwertbare Beweise sammelt dass
man wirklich mit einem guten Grund sagen
kann das entfällt schon und selbst dann
wie gesagt
Beschlagnahme und Hausdurchsuchung sind
auch nicht was man einfach so machen
kann das ist in Deutschland auch
hochreguliert wir müssen nach den Regeln
spielen die anderen müssen das nicht tun
also sie müssen es natürlich tun es
nicht und deswegen ist es immer ein
bisschen wie ein Wettlauf wie schätzen
Sie die Dimension des Ganzen ein wir
haben es dort mit
Organisationsstrukturen zu tun die dem
eines unternehmensgleichen wir haben ein
ich nehme
exactive Officer der die Strategie
bestimmt wir haben darunter eine gewisse
Management Ebene wir haben einen Einkauf
und wir haben Sheltie people die
Verkäufer sie haben also tatsächlich
eine Organisation wie in einem
verkaufenden Unternehmen in einem
Handelsunternehmen wenn wir so wollen
ähm also da ist ein ganz ganz vor
Organisationsgrad da und der ist nicht
nur wie gesagt auf einem Land beschränkt
das ist auch ein großes Problem bei der
Bekämpfung das muss man ehrlich sagen
dass ich über diverse Länder verteilt
die Türkei ist einer der
hauptknotenpunkte im Handel mit Fakes
und auch als Produzent spielt sie eine
immer wichtigere Rolle wer hier den
richtigen Accounts folgt bekommt tiefer
Einblick in die Produktion und
Organisation des ganzen
fälschernetzwerks das wissen auch
deutsche Händler zu schätzen dieser hier
zum Beispiel nimmt seine Kundschaft mit
live über Instagram zu seinem
Großhändler und Produzenten bis nach
Istanbul ich habe mir die Sachen des
Insiders mal angeschaut das ist ein Shop
der wahrscheinlich die anderen Shops in
der Nähe beliefert oder zumindest einen
davon und das ist gerade so ein bisschen
unsere heißeste Spur und deswegen
fliegen wir da jetzt hin
wir sind jetzt angekommen mitten in der
Innenstadt von Istanbul super viel los
das Gebäude ist da gegenüber also wie
man sieht einfach ein Büro Komplex wir
haben gerade schon Videos geschickt
bekommen mit Anweisungen die man
reinkommt also aus dem Codewort was man
da vor Ort sagen soll und dann gehen wir
jetzt mal hin
in den Aufzug kommen wir nur mit
Codewort uns ist also klar die haben
keinen Bock auf Laufkundschaft
[Musik]
wir haben uns als Touristen ausgegeben
und landen in einer Edelboutique hier
kaufen auch Inhaber illegaler Shops in
Deutschland ein wir merken schnell dass
sie größere Umsätze erwartet werden als
wir zögern wir Druck aufgebaut wir
brauchen die Produkte für unsere
Recherche und geben nach erst als wir
für umgerechnet mehrere hundert Euro
einkaufen entspannt sich die Situation
wir gucken mal rein Gucci
Gucci
das ist natürlich schon eine Ansage
qualitativ aber auch auf jeden Fall viel
besser als das aus Deutschland
[Musik]
viele Label dran auch so labbriger
fällt mir dann doch was auf also hier
ist auch ein deutscher Text angesichts
der besonderen Art von Druck
irgendwelche Mängel auf diese Artikel
ist eine Eigenschaft von das Produkt
also ganz viel Mühe scheint sich dann
doch nicht gegeben zu haben
ja zurück in Deutschland ich habe diesen
Koffer komplett voll mit gefälschten
Luxusmarken Sachen die ich in
Deutschland niemals leisten kann einfach
so durch den Zoll geschoben oder gar
kein Problem und ja kein Wunder dass man
überall in Deutschland kaufen kann
obwohl der Handel mit gefälschten
Produkten in Deutschland strafbar ist
kommen sie leicht ins Land wie das
passiert und welche Netzwerke dahinter
stecken damit beschäftigt sich Felipe
Thomas Professor für Marketing mit dem
Fokus auf digitale Schwarzmärkte er
arbeitet zusammen mit Google Meter und
Twitter und berät Regierungen im Umgang
mit Kriminalität im Internet
große Plattformen wie Instagram sind wie
ein Trichter hier werden viele Leute
abgegriffen und erreicht zwar wird nicht
jeder der hier angesprochen wird auch
etwas kaufen aber es ist ein guter Pool
für Fälscher sie brauchen einen
öffentlichen Ort mit viel Bewegung und
Austausch um Käufer zu finden jeder kann
mit diesem Algorithmus spielen weil er
Teil der Plattform ist alle Technologien
die geschaffen wurden um Abläufe zu
verbessern werden eben auch von Leuten
zum eigenen Vorteil genutzt
da eine Struktur dahinter
ich glaube als Verbraucher ist es sehr
einfach sich das alles anzusehen und zu
sagen ach das ist doch nur ein Schuh
eine Uhr was auch immer in den meisten
meiner Studien sieht man dass kriminelle
Machenschaften ein Business sind
die Hintermänner kümmern sich nicht um
Menschen sie kümmern sich nicht darum
was sie da genau tun sie interessieren
sich nur für den Prophet
die andere Sache die ich für wichtig
halte ist dass die Grenzkontrollen laxer
werden ein Beamter irgendeiner irgendwo
muss ein Auge zudrücken und sagen wisst
ihr was es ist in Ordnung ich werde
einfach in die andere Richtung schauen
und es kann weitergehen das ist die
Lücke durch die schließlich noch andere
Dinge durchgeschlossen werden warum kann
die Polizei nichts dagegen tun es ist
wie bei einer Hydra wenn man ihr einen
Kopf abschlägt wachsen drei neue Köpfe
nach
und das ist ein Teil des Problems mit
dem die Strafverfolgungsbehörden auf dem
digitalen Schwarzmarkt konfrontiert
werden
denn organisierte Kriminalität ist so
aufgebaut dass am Ende immer die Person
gefunden wird von der die Hintermänner
wollten dass man sie findet
ich habe ein gefälschten Schuh für 250
Dollar in einem Laden hier in
Deutschland gekauft wer wird daran
verdient
wenn du denkst ach es ist doch nur
dieser einzelne Händler in Deutschland
der will nur sich und seine Familie über
die Runden bringen wie schlimm kann es
schon sein ihn zu unterstützen dann
könnte man wieder denken dass es in
diesem Geschäft eigentlich keine
richtigen Opfer gibt
wenn man sich jedoch vor Augen führt
dass all diese Dinge in der Regel mit
organisierten Formen des Verbrechens
Zusammenhängen dann stößt man auf
weitaus ernstere und gefährlichere
Formen von Kriminalität
eine Menge dieser grau und Schwarzmarkt
Transaktionen haben über ein Jahrzehnt
hinweg die Operationen des is-finanziert
[Musik]
es ist eine Menge Geld mit dem viele
schlimme Dinge finanziert werden
mein gefälschter Sneaker ist also
vielleicht Teil der organisierten
Kriminalität ich will wissen wer in
Deutschland verfolgt überhaupt illegale
Produktfälschungen die auf Instagram
vertrieben werden
das BKA sagt nee das ist nicht unsere
Aufgabe und die verweisen dann auf den
Zoll die Bundespolizei sagt auch nee
damit haben wir nichts zu tun und
verweist auf den Zoll und auf die
landespolizeibehörden wir fragen bei der
Landespolizei in NRW ob sie überhaupt
Erkenntnisse haben in welcher Dimension
ist solche Shops gibt und die haben dann
auch geantwortet relativ ausführlich und
sagten unter anderem dass sie weder zur
Anzahl der Shops in NRW noch zur
Dimension des Problems Erkenntnisse
vorliegen haben ja und dann gibt's noch
den Zoll sie gehen in ihrer
Stellungnahme zwar auf die Existenz von
organisierter Kriminalität auf Social
Media ein und Schreiben sofern Hinweise
zu Verkäufen von Fälschungen über Social
Media Plattformen wie Instagram eingehen
wird diesen seitens das
zollkriminalamtes nachgegangen wenn der
Betroffene Rechte Inhaber an einer
Strafverfolgung interessiert ist und der
zollfahndungsdienst Ermittlungen
aufnimmt wird immer auch der Bereich der
organisierten Kriminalität geprüft
der Zoll sieht sich nicht für die
Ermittlungen auf Social Media
Plattformen zuständig konkret heißt es
die Überprüfung des Angebots von
mutmaßlich schutzrechtsverletzenden
waren auf Internetplattformen oder der
Inhalte dieser Webseiten unterliegt
nicht der Zuständigkeit der
Zollverwaltung dabei ist der Schaden
immens der Wert der aufgegriffenen
fake-schuhe belief sich laut Zoll in
Deutschland 2021 auf über 17 Millionen
Euro der Zoll kontrolliert ja Einfuhren
nicht nur danach ob sie sich um
Originalprodukte handelt er muss ja auch
noch
kontrollieren Drogen waffengeschützt
haben also er hat ein großes
Aufgabenspektrum das alles kann ja nur
mit einer gewissen
Mannstärke Personalstärke abdecken
wissen sie ungefähr wie viel dadurch
geht oder wie viel der Zoll überhaupt
kontrolliert ja also wie gesagt so
derzeit glaube ich sind wir so ungefähr
bei 10% der Sendung die die geprüft
werden okay
der Zoll will das nicht kommentieren
belastbares Zahlenmaterial lege hierzu
nicht vor stimmt die Annahme von 10%
würde der Schaden von aufgegriffenen
Schuhen im dreistelligen
Millionenbereich liegen es sind
tatsächlich alle Sachen die ich über
insta in China bestellt habe bei mir
angekommen die Händler haben schnell
geliefert und nichts ist beim Zoll
hängen geblieben über Instagram alles
kein Problem was wir festgestellt haben
die Sachen die wir im Shop hier vor Ort
gekauft haben die sind mit hoher
Wahrscheinlichkeit aus der Türkei und
auch dort hergestellt das liegt vor
allem an der einfacheren Logistik die
deutschen Händler können leichter
Kontakte knüpfen auch mal eben in die
Türkei fliegen sich die Sachen vor Ort
angucken und dann haben wir noch die
ganzen Sachen aus China hier bis sie
hier waren hat es ungefähr immer so zwei
bis vier Wochen gedauert und qualitativ
gibt's da große Unterschied jetzt haben
wir z.B den Schuh hier da kenne ich
sogar als Laie das ist relativ hartes
Material billig verarbeitet der wird auf
jeden Fall gefälscht sein
aber es gibt natürlich dann noch die
super Clowns wie diese beiden hier und
da ein Unterschied zum Original
festzustellen dass fällt mir auf jeden
Fall nicht so leicht die sind für mich
kaum zu unterscheiden vom Original
super Clowns bieten weitere
Möglichkeiten für das schnelle Geld auf
Instagram bekommt man sogar Anleitungen
die beschreiben wie ich gefälschte
Schuhe gegen echte austauschen und dann
im Laden zurückgeben kann so ich habe
mich jetzt in Schale geschmissen denn
jetzt ist die Stunde der Wahrheit und
ich versuche diese gefälschten Schuhe im
Original Laden umzutauschen die
Fälschung haben 250 € gekostet und das
Original 850 gestern im Laden und ich
packe jetzt einfach mal die gefälschten
Schuhe in den Originalkarton und jeder
mit laden und versucht das umzutauschen
wir drehen mit versteckter Kamera ich
müsste die einmal umtauschen ja dann
nehme ich dir erstmal zurück ja cool
dann gerne einmal hier die Karte
draufhalten
850 € gehen dann zurück drauf ich gebe
noch mal die anderen Belege mit Ja
vielen lieben Dank ja perfekt danke
schön
Entschuldigung wir müssen mal was
aufklären ich habe tatsächlich gerade
gefälschte Schuhe abgegeben bei Ihnen
die sind super gut gefälscht erwischt ja
aber es ist alles gut ich habe die
originalen tatsächlich auch hier und man
kann es auch wirklich nicht erkennen er
sieht sehr gut aus erstmal merkt man es
nicht wenn man ihn in die Hand nimmt
merkt man das auf jeden Fall aber ich
hätte jetzt kein zweites Paar dazu
genommen um zu gucken ob der leichter
oder schwerer ist
also das war super einfach ich bin in
Laden reingelaufen habe den Karton auf
den Tresen gestellt die Kollegin hatte
mir nach hinten genommen kam mit
demselben Gang eigentlich schon mit dem
EC-Gerät zurück hat mir meine Kohle
zurück überwiesen und ich hätte einfach
aus dem Laden gehen können mit dem Geld
die Verkäuferinnen haben bei der
Rückgabe nichts bemerkt ich will mein
Urteil darüber wie gut die Fälschungen
tatsächlich geworden sind aber nicht an
dem einen Fall festmachen deshalb fahre
ich zu einem Reseller der
echtheitsprüfungen anbietet
deswegen checken wir auch wie gesagt nur
nagelneue Schuhe weil bei gebrauchten
Schuhen kann ich den Geruch von der
Factory nicht einschätzen ja dass der
Original und das der gefällt steht wenn
du selbst mal riechst ja der riecht viel
giftiger sondern das für die Fakes immer
ein klares Indiz aber von der Form muss
man sagen es ist schon gut gemacht auf
jeden Fall gucken wir hier vorne auch
immer auf wie ist die Verarbeitung hier
in dieser Stelle ist quasi zugenäht das
hier schon auf jeden Fall siehst du auch
deutlich schlechter verarbeitet also
hier gehen die nette halt schon direkt
drauf original sitzt die Farbe bei
deutlich dunkler ne gucken wir mal nach
unten drunter ist nur davon kannst du
für dich besser aussieht
ja das untere 4 dünner geschrieben ja
auch schon sehr auffällig
aber da braucht man ja schon fast ein
also so ein Produkt was man vergleichen
kann genau also mit so hättest ohne Box
ja und wenn du auch nicht willst dass
ich die Farbcode sage ich mal ein
bisschen unterscheiden dann ist es ganz
schwierig zu erkennen gerade als Laie
der fängt man sich auf jeden Fall
Millionen wenn ich sogar Milliarden
Business es gibt Leute die was ganz groß
aufgezogen sage ich mal wirklich mit
eigener Fabrik mit sich Mitarbeitern
Instagram Promotor Promo wurde die
Dinger halt wirklich echt günstiger
werden kannst wir haben auch Instagram
angefragt die gehören ja zu Meter
inwieweit sie sich in der Verantwortung
sehen und auf keine unserer Fragen haben
Sie konkret geantwortet die Plattform
arbeite eng mit den
Strafverfolgungsbehörden zusammen und
dulde keinen Betrug was heißt das
konkret wir haben ihn einige Accounts
geschickt und dazu schreibt Meter
Metas Richtlinien erlauben weder den
Verkauf noch die Bewerbung von
gefälschten Produkten Inhalte die gegen
diese Richtlinien verstoßen werden
entfernt wir haben den betreffenden
Inhalt gelöscht die von uns geschickten
Account sind tatsächlich gelöscht worden
alle anderen Accounts aus dem selben
Netzwerk die man mit einem Klick findet
sind allerdings noch da also geändert
hat sich nicht so viel
auf meiner Reise durch die schöne Welt
von Instagram bin ich innerhalb
kürzester Zeit da gelandet wo es gar
nicht mehr so schön war bei kriminellen
die durch Produktfälschungen Milliarden
machen also ja es gibt organisierte
Kriminalität auf Instagram
Polizei und Zoll haben das nicht
wirklich auf dem Schirm die Fälscher
nutzen das aus um ihr Geschäft immer
weiter auszubauen eine Lücke die zwar
gesehen aber nicht geschlossen wird
[Musik]